كيمون
جميل
لوحاته بحجم الحدث الاستثنائيه
الذي جسدها امرا واقعا
على كسب الرهان
من حيث المعظم
البعد الثاني دوله قطر البعد الثالث هي
التضامني مع الدروس قطر
[موسيقى]
وبالكلمه والنعم عبر فنانون موريتانيون
بطريقتهم الخاصه عن دعمهم لدوله قطر
[موسيقى]
الاغنيه حول جماليه وخصوصيه الملاعب التي
انشاتها قطر في استضافه المونديال
[موسيقى]
كما تحكي مراحل التحضير لهذا الحدث
العالمي
امك
محدوده لكن بالاصرار والتحدي الذي تعلمناه
من قطع عليه نخرج بهذا العمل الذي نرجوا
من الله ان شاء الله ان همم
اعجاب القائم على هذا الكاس ونتمنى لقطار
المزيد من الاستحرار
وير الموريتانيون في هذه التظاهرات مناسبه
لتوحيد الصف العربي وتجاوز الخلافات
السياسيه والانفتاح على الاخرين دون
التفريط في القيم والمبادئ
تعريف
ودعايه للقضيه المركزيه بالنسبه لجميع
العرب اللي هي فلسطين اللي كان علمها
مرفوع في كل ااه مكان
[تصفيق]
ولكن موريتانيا لمرجان قطر شهدت التظاهره
نسبه مشاهده عاليه وسطا بهار بمستوى
التنظيم وحجم الحضور في الملاعب
[تصفيق]
سيبقى مونديال قطر خالدا في الذاكره
الجمعيه للموريتانيين دون شك كما يظهر من
خلال ردود فعل الجمهور الشغوفي بالمستديره
الذي احتفى بمستوى تنظيم